so after Joe Biden the other big loser
on Tuesday was another ex frontrunner
Elizabeth Warren she finished fourth she
did barely half the votes of the
third-place finisher Amy Klobuchar if
you'd barely half the votes of Amy
Klobuchar art no offense to Amy
Klobuchar not good so officially
Elizabeth Warren's presidential campaign
is still going nobody believes really it
means anything in fact we can't say at
this point what exactly Elizabeth Warren
is running for maybe she hopes to get a
few delegates she can exchange for a
cabinet job if the Democrat wins maybe
she wants to sabotage Bernie Sanders
because he's a sexist by siphoning votes
from him well maybe she just liked
traveling around giving speeches of lots
of servants around her and flying on
private plans what she loves to do but
one thing for certain Warren is not
running for president because she thinks
she can become president because she can
despite that in a non concession speech
last night and this is very telling
Warren bragged about taking half the
bank account of a broke college student
to finance her doomed ambitions watch
this young woman came up by herself and
she said I'm a broke college student
with a lot of student loan debt and she
said I checked and I have six dollars in
the bank so I just gave three dollars to
keep you in this fight that's what we
got to do we got to stay in this fight
with people who are counting on us she's
literally begging money from the
indigent to continue a campaign that
can't win it's not really a campaign at
that point it's a religious movement or
a cult or something but really didn't
even happen is the story real who knows
Warren has been caught lying about so
many things we can actually check just
imagine what she says when she can't be
caught I mean really so it's tempting to
say that Warren collapsed that her
campaign died because she lies a lot but
that's actually not the case
Warren's been lying for a long time she
pretended to be an American Indian
remember that that happened before she
launched her campaign voters knew it and
yet for a while she was the Democratic
frontrunner so clearly Democrats were
willing to forgive for fabrications no
she destroyed her campaign for different
much more interesting reason Warren fell
apart for the same reason that beta were
work did because in place of a message
an actual message that unites people
and ideas and policies she went all in
on woke nests all in every public
appearance brought out a new facet to
her remarkable woken us there was her
Town Hall endorsing race-based
reparations I believe it's time to start
the National full-blown conversation
about reparations so she wrote that for
a while but then by summer that wasn't
enough reparations old hat but Warren is
nothing if not creative so she invented
a brand new kind of racism a whole new
category watch this now where the
president is advancing environmental
racism economic racism criminal justice
racism health care racism yep Warren was
pledging to fight healthcare racism is
that committed by doctor she never
explained our nurses committing
healthcare racism who knows but she was
going to eliminate it it was the last
thing she did but then she kept going by
early this year Warren was promising to
let transgender children pick her
cabinet members for real I'm gonna have
a Secretary of Education that this young
trans person interviews on my behalf and
only if this person believes that our
secretary or Secretary of Education
nominee is someone who is committed to
creating a welcoming environment a safe
environment and a full educational
curriculum for everyone well that person
actually be advanced to be Secretary of
Education
[Applause]
so was that pandering was that scripted
no it wasn't no lobby group told her to
say that you couldn't make that up she
came to that on her own
cuz you know what she meant it after a
while the woke nests infected her brain
so completely took over Elizabeth Warren
that she really believed what she was
saying and it got crazier and crazier
reparations for gay couples great idea
gender non-binary people the backbone
of our democracy she literally said that
eventually it was too much even for
liberals they looked at this and said
what's what the hell are you talking
about Bernie Sanders meaning I was
promising universal health care
something they actually want whether
it's a good idea or not something people
wanted Warren tried to jump on and
promise the same thing except she said
she would magically do it without
raising taxes on the middle class again
even Democrats couldn't buy it after a
while when Warren finally gives up this
charade I'm running for president no
you're not please will you'll be able to
sum her campaign up in three words died
of woken us